bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy
in an interest bearing account or you
can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got zach
here with me thanks so much for doing
this sir
yeah no problem happy to be here for
sure so you are the only person i know
in the world that was
a solo founder and also solo employee
uh of a business that you ran for
multiple years uh you eventually grew it
to
seven million dollars in revenue by
yourself uh
what happened and how the hell did you
do that
um well you know i was really the
internal employee but i had a lot of
external help
um working with you know a lot of third
that you know a production partner who
was overseeing our manufacturing and so
you know was fortunate i i met a lot of
helpful people along the way
um and i i was
super sensitive to you know hiring too
quickly and i wanted to stay away from
raising funding and so that just kind of
forced me to be as lean as possible and
so
i wasn't ready to really bring on talent
until i knew i could sustain them and
the business could sustain them and so
yeah and then we were fortunate we
launched a product that
uh kind of resonated right out the gate
and so during that three and a half
years uh if you're the only internal
employee you basically are doing
everything uh what did your day look
like were you just
awake for like 20 hours a day or kind of
what were you doing
uh yeah it was pretty intense um
[Music]
i mean yeah i mean there's a lot you
know
a lot of customer support stuff that
ended up being getting customer support
got to a place where he's like okay i
can't
obviously we need help there um product
development
you know marketing um yeah touching a
lot of different areas and
um you know it was kind of like doing
part-time of what you know we have our
employees do full-time now and just
probably not
being at a size where it required
someone to be full-time um
but yeah kind of all day thinking about
the business and and trying to advance
it however best
yeah and so what was your background
before you started public rec
uh i i was working in finance beforehand
uh i
previously directly worked for a private
equity firm and before that i
worked in investment banking for a few
years out of school
and so was it just you had uncomfortable
pants and you wanted more comfortable
pants like what was the impetus for the
idea
actually i mean a little bit um so you
know sweatpants never fit in me well
uh me being shorter and so like swept
like
in college i gravitated towards one pair
of sweatpants and actually ended up
fitting
they happened to be my mom's and i was
like oh why do these fit why do i like
these more because they fit better
they're shorter in length so it's like
why aren't you know leisure pants
sweatpants offering a waste and in seam
sizing if they were
they could fit better it felt like a
problem that other brands were ignoring
because of the inventory risk
and the investment and like trying to do
it differently and so it felt like a way
to differentiate the product was
offer waste and length sizing for
leisure pants
for sure so when you go to launch this
thing you have a kickstarter campaign
for my understanding and you do six
figures in revenue through that
kickstarter campaign
why kickstarter and kind of what did you
do to increase the odds of it being
successful
yeah at the time kickstarter felt like
uh a good place to really test the
market immediately
uh and you know get feedback understand
if the message was resonating if people
were interested in the product at all
um and then like also garner some pr
um you know at the time when you were
having success on kickstarter
and it still is but like it's a very
public um
display of your business and everyone
can see the number that you've raised
and it's like
oh this company you know they have
credibility because they've
done this much on kickstarter or it's
you know it's resonating with other
customers maybe i should check them out
and so
yeah i i spent six months in advance of
really
dialing in the campaign making the video
um
having a final prototype uh and feeling
good about where i was
with the manufacturer and the content
and the story um and then also you know
reaching out to writers in advance to
kind of tell them this was coming and
hope that maybe they may be interested
enough to to write about us
for sure and so when you think through
uh kind of
where you've evolved to today how do you
describe public rec and what you guys
are doing
we're a leisure apparel brand uh
mainly direct to consumer online uh
making super comfortable clothes you can
still feel good about wearing outside of
the house um
yeah we you know i can go into it more
throughout this but yeah
we spend a ton of time making product
and sourcing fabrics and making sure
that whatever
you know we're coming out with is
different and better than than what's
out there today
and when you think through the business
uh being d to c obviously i think has
uh kind of swept through a bunch of
these different industries but it seems
like every d2c company eventually tries
to get into
uh physical retail retail locations
why stay d2c for the most part
yeah um i think
it was kind of just out of what was
working and like where we felt the scale
like you know we were fortunate that the
message was resonating kind of as we
scaled our marketing budget
digitally um and so i was like you know
let's just keep doing this
you know we see we spend a dollar we get
you know
two and a half dollars three dollars
back in revenue this is great this makes
sense for the business it's profitable
um you know how much more can we push
this okay we need to get we'll get more
inventory to support how much more we
can push it and so it was kind of just
like
just keep doing kind of what's working
for the time being um
we launched one store in new york uh it
was open for about six months
unfortunately
we closed it uh due to cobit and we kind
of walked away from it
it's a you know a strategy we're
reassessing and probably will pursue at
some point um
but you know the capital required to do
it uh
and the amount of revenue it can drive
versus just kind of building the brand
online it just felt like it made sense
to
stay focused on the web business yeah
and what i think stands out about the
product that you've built is you are
product first right this idea of comfort
it's all over the marketing materials
it's literally when you describe the
company
uh when you wear the clothes they just
feel better
um where does that kind of product
obsession come from
uh and then kind of do you do anything
inside of the company to continue to
just hammer that home to employees
partners vendors etc about that
kind of focus on quality of product yeah
um to me it was like
you know i only want to do this i only
want to start a company if you know
i feel like we can make something that's
better than what's out there today
because like
you know we're starting with a no-name
brand we're only going to win
and we're only going to attract
customers if our product is great
and then like you know everything else
has to make sense and work and
but to me it's like start with trying to
make a product that
we think is better than what's out there
currently and that customers are going
to enjoy um
and so you know the first product took a
couple years to make
uh sourcing different fabrics finding
different factories finally got to a
place where i felt good about the fabric
the fit
um and it's kind of been you know that
way since we've launched products we try
to think of things as core
we don't think of them as seasonal or
discount them
um and we try to i mean we'll spend
anywhere from 18 to 36 months
uh from idea to the products in our
fulfillment center and ready to sell to
our customers because
uh i just feel like we don't have the
opportunity to get it wrong
like customers are trusting us it's a
leap of faith to try a new brand
if the product isn't excellent they're
not coming back
they're not talking about us to friends
and family and nothing else works if uh
people don't love the product yeah and
so
how do you measure whether people
actually love it right obviously there's
sales is there anything else that you
guys look at
to really measure how much people love
the product
uh we look at repeat rate we look at
you know customer feedback we're getting
reviews from customers
we're looking at you know how people
talk about the brand on you know
different places
um you know whether it be ads or
responding to emails
the type of inbound we get um
and then it's like you know friends
family all that's like anyone who's
experienced the brand it's always
interesting to get their perspective
usually it's you know you got to
understand that a lot of it can be
biased because you know if they're
friends or family sometimes they don't
want to be critical then there's like
the friends or family
who like want to be super critical which
is which is helpful
um yeah yeah uh but you know trying to
listen to the customer as much as
possible
so when we talk today uh you've got
you know double-digit employees uh
you're profitable
you've raised uh no kind of venture
capital uh
and uh you've really built a great
business uh we started this conversation
off with the idea that uh you were a
solo employee
up to seven million dollars in revenue
when did you know it was time to bring
on other people
like was there a moment where you're
like oh man i am overwhelmed uh i
really really need help like what drove
you to finally get another employee
um it was yeah it was something i
i remember like up until that time it
was like a big internal debate of like
should we hire no i can keep going i can
keep doing this but then it was like at
some point i was like
you know this isn't sustainable you know
the goal is to build a big brand
um i can we can afford to hire someone
and support that salary
um so it was just i think
everything just kind of tipped to like
okay if we're if i'm gonna keep doing
this for a long time
and build a big brand you know i need to
start hiring people
especially if the business can support
it um so yeah
a few a few different variables kind of
were all telling me you know
now is the time to hire
i absolutely love the fact that you did
that uh
talk to me a little bit about the idea
of not high or uh not raising any
venture capital right
uh you did kickstarter so there's kind
of some initial funding but it really
was kind of this pre-order model
was it intentional not to raise venture
capital uh or did it just kind of happen
like
what was that uh that story
i think in the beginning um
i had saved a little bit from my
previous jobs and we i had done the
kickstarter so
you know i felt like i had a little
runway to test out the idea
uh and see you know what could become of
it
at some point i raised a small round
from friends and family a couple years
in to
support you know moving manufacturing
overseas with higher minimums and to
make more products than just the pants
um but i i you know
we were fortunate we had pretty quick
growth
over the first few years and it was
everything was moving so quickly that it
was like
i didn't think that raising equity would
really change the path we were on and so
it's like you know we're growing quickly
i already feel like it's as risky as you
know i'm comfortable with it
as it is given the pace we're moving yet
so it's like i don't want to
put more fuel on the fire and you know
accelerate the risk and maybe make some
decisions that i'm not as comfortable
with
and i'm happy with like the growth we're
seeing so in the beginning it was
just being okay with you know the growth
rate at which we were on
and not feeling like equity would really
change that path
um yeah got it
and so when you think about um kind of
that path
would you go back and do it differently
would you have raised capital
uh do you think this was the right way
to do it would you be in a different
position if you had raised capital
um i don't think i would do it
differently
i you know sometimes i think about what
where we would be if if we had raised
capital and you know would we be
three to five years ahead of where we
are today um
but no i mean i i i i chose the path and
i you know i have no regrets about the
path and
um i think it's been right for us as a
company
the one thing is like you know there are
some brands
that end up raising a ton of capital and
they maybe find out that you know
sometimes the the financials don't make
sense and they're scaling on financials
or metrics
kpis that don't make sense um
i do think that we kind of have you know
we're fortunate
we have this product and we have kpis
that kind of make sense
now to scale and um you know financing
might kind of change where we are today
but um
yeah no i i mean i it was a good path
for us and
uh i would i would pursue it again the
same way
yeah talk to me about your supply chain
obviously with uh kovid and kind of
everything that's happened
uh over the last year i'm assuming that
there was a ton of uh
issues there and that you had to
navigate but uh just maybe explain a
little bit about how the supply chain
set up and then what you've had to uh
navigate over the last year
yeah we so we make everything uh
most of our stuff is made in thailand
indonesia and peru
um when when covet hit
we we had a decent amount of inventory
of kind of all of our products
so we didn't have a lot of pos that were
coming so it wasn't like we needed to
shift
you know and slow down pos we also
you know we found out kind of later
throughout kobe we didn't really
we hadn't really tested what the
capacity levels were at our factories
because we weren't really placing a
bunch of orders and so
um something that we experienced was
after the holidays we had a good q4 we
had an encouraging holiday
and you know we wanted to order more we
found out kind of
november that stuff that was supposed to
hit end of december
wasn't going to hit and it was going to
be six to eight weeks delayed and so
uh q1 this year january and february we
were out of product
in a lot of our core skus because of
factory delays i think
something that we experienced was a lot
of our factories slowed down last summer
they laid people off unfortunately and
they didn't have the same capacities
that they used to have and then a lot of
brands i think started seeing success
q4 last year were starting to ramp up
the factories no longer had the same
capacity so they couldn't keep up and so
um yeah it's it's been difficult for us
uh
the last you know four or five months
having product on hand
feeling good about you know continuing
to keep product on hand i think we're
now at a point that will be
you know hopefully good through the rest
of the year um
but yeah it's been a challenge for sure
and part of having a really strong
supply chain
not having raised capital you know
really kind of working your
ass off in terms of uh those first
couple of years
uh one of the benefits of all that is
you're profitable
you've been profitable for quite a while
uh talk through maybe the pros and cons
of uh being profitable early did that
change from the decision making that you
may
have made otherwise and then have you
seen that as an advantage as you've
built the business over the last few
years
i think i think so the advantage is like
you know we get to make our own
decisions on where we want to go and
what we want to do for the most part
we'll not be holding to an investor
we're not beholden to trying to you know
get more money
from you know an outside person
institution whatever it may be
um which has been super helpful in terms
of like
you know we're operating the business on
a daily basis and so everyone internally
you know the team now today we're making
decisions on what we think makes sense
for the business and we're able to
execute it without feeling
like you know when you check with
someone or when you do something
differently
um i think it's also it's given us a
little more room
you know i i think it's kept us
disciplined in like how we think about
marketing and where we want to go
and um you know
the the con or the drawback is maybe
that like
you know we've been uh less aggressive
in our marketing
uh and so you know maybe we haven't
grown as quickly as we otherwise would
have if we had you know
a bunch more capital to try to test
things um
but you know obviously with the testing
you find out what works you find out
what it does we've been able to test a
good amount
um but yeah maybe maybe you know the
outside capital help makes us accelerate
our testing a bit more
and um you know allows us to do things
that we would find out that do work for
us that we've been
maybe hesitant to do um
yeah talk to me about the changes
in consumer behavior that you've seen
through the last 12 months covid the
economic crisis etc
are there specific things that stick out
in your mind uh that maybe other people
aren't aware of
yeah um
although although people may already be
aware of it or you know have heard it
from others
um you know mid-march those
mid-march up until really may it was
very slow for us you know and the the
website fell off in a way that it was
like
you know when you're experiencing it we
don't know what's going on with kobe we
don't know how long it's going to last
and it's at a point where it's like
if we keep seeing revenue like this on a
daily basis
i don't know how long we can survive
like is this a six month a 12-month
thing we're just you know people aren't
spending or buying our clothes and
um so that was super scary we started to
see an uptick throughout the summer
we saw people buying a lot of shorts um
and then you know the fall was pretty
good we again
we saw slow down for the election but i
think that's you know outside of kobe we
probably would have seen that and then
we had we had a good holiday season
which i remember even going into black
friday
in cyber monday not really knowing how
it was going to go
and then you know seeing what the
performance was like and seeing what the
you know consumer what the consumer was
buying and that you know
so that was exciting and then and then
of course we find out shortly thereafter
that
you know the the product's not going to
hit that we thought for the restocks and
now we're going to be out of stock and
so
um yeah i mean i think it's probably
similar to what other businesses banks
have experienced in terms of like you
know a dramatic
drop-off in demand and then a slow
rebound and you know
it's it's feeling good now again so yeah
well it's incredible to uh to kind of go
through those peaks and valleys all
in a short compressed period of time
right uh it takes the the whole idea of
being an entrepreneur and puts it on
steroids when you've got the uh the
macro environment going so crazy
um one of the things that i find
fascinating about your business
is this focus on comfort but i gotta ask
how do you
measure comfort is it just you put the
clothes on you're like yup this is
comfortable nope this is not
uh do you have like a panel is it
friends and family like
who is the determination uh factor
around what is actually comfortable
what's not oh
that's a good question uh
i mean it's friends and family you know
i started a cooling company because i
had a strong opinion in clothing and
felt like i had a good
barometer for that stuff um but of
course like i'm only one person i you
know i don't have a background in
clothing so
uh yeah as prototypes come in it's
you know putting them on different
people seeing what their reaction is you
know
if it's friends or family and they're
trying it like forcing them as much as
possible to be critical
and like you know not hold back um
and then like you know as we've come out
with products and we get feedback on
what people are liking and not liking
then we can
refine and dial it in and do more of or
do less of
if you could go back uh and unpack kind
of that first three and a half years
when you're working by yourself
uh what are the things that kept you
going was it something that you were
telling yourself
was it uh the fear of failure was it
just every day you looked for one
positive sign to kind of keep you moving
forward like
what was the thing that kept you going
for three and a half years by yourself
um and really from a perspective of
there's a lot of people listening to
this who
uh they're early right whether they're
actually by themselves or it feels like
they're by themselves
uh they're very very early in that
journey and they're constantly looking
for
uh the right signs that they're on the
right path and they can keep kind of
uh pushing forward what was it for you
that kept you there
i think i mean every day was exciting to
me
every day was something new um i still i
remember feeling like you know getting
to the weekends and still like
doing stuff that i could do myself over
the weekends but being so eager to for
it to be monday because like
i know people were online and they'd be
responding to emails or
be able to take phone calls and so
that i mean like it was it was i mean it
still is so exciting but that was you
know something that it was just like i
it just didn't feel like a job at the
time it was like you know i am so
dedicated to this i
i'm loving it and it's like you know
still super stressful and you know
making mistakes and not doing everything
well and
um but you know
the excitement and then and then it's
like you know if i'm not doing anything
nothing's getting done so it's like the
only way that i can keep doing this and
sustain the excitement and you know
enjoy this is like okay we need to
progress the business so we can
you know get to a place where it's
financially sustainable
yeah and was there a moment when you
said to yourself
it's working like was it the kickstarter
and you're like oh you know people want
this
uh was there like a dollar figure in the
bank or revenue or like
what was that moment when you're like
damn like i actually made it like make
this work
um
so i think probably when i made the
first tire when it's like when
i was like okay this is working um it's
still like even today it's like
you know i'm checking the numbers
constantly and if something doesn't look
good for the last hour it's like what
happened
is the sight down you know the lights
could turn off at any minute and i still
fear that
fear um
yeah yeah it's still i mean like the
goal is hopefully you know something
bigger and you know hopefully
just getting started but yeah do you
watch the numbers on like an
hour-by-hour basis
yeah i do it's not healthy no it look i
actually think it's
one of the best signs of you really
understand the business right like i
could probably ask you
you know what are the uh most popular
hours of shopping versus not
and you intuitively just know because if
you watch the numbers all day long right
yeah yeah um when i started the
so we're on shopify and
initially there's a shopify app so you
you could get a notification every time
a purchase came through to your phone
and it was like a dopamine hit like
every because i would know what the
vibrate or the sound was
and now i mean i've turned that off the
the notification at least
um but yeah i still check uh
you know very often and part of it part
of it's like
now we're at a point where we have a
team and like if something's going wrong
you know someone will someone will catch
it our customer support team will catch
it or you know
the person who oversees our site will
catch it uh but in the beginning was
like
i may be the only one who catches it if
it's like you know the last hour we
haven't had any traffic on the site
something
maybe the site's down or something so
that was part of it i think
yeah it's so funny the uh that shopify
notification with the uh cash register
noise
uh i i i've got a uh two friends uh who
are the founders of atoms the
shoe company oh yeah [ __ ] and i was over
at their house
uh six months ago or maybe even a year
ago at this point
and uh it kept going off and i just
looked at it at one point they're like
yeah we're not shutting that off
right it was just this thing of like it
was annoying but it was like
hey man we just know that like you know
things are working and
it's pretty cool to kind of see shopify
specifically like their whole
uh mentality of like arming the rebels
right i've had uh harley the uh the
president of shopify on the podcast
before and i think that just hearing
uh kind of their focus on celebrating
entrepreneurship and really
empowering entrepreneurs seems like
you're like the quintessential story for
a platform like shopify
right where basically uh you didn't need
a big team uh you simply needed the
platform
and once you had the tools then you kind
of get to work and can build a business
uh and turn into something pretty
special create jobs for people
uh and and really kind of uh embrace all
that entrepreneurship
that everyone always talks about yeah
yeah shopify has been a great platform
for us i remember
uh in the beginning it was like you know
shopify or squarespace and
at the time it was like there wasn't it
was hard for me to tell the difference
between them
some people are on squarespace and i'm
yeah i
feel fortunate that we went with shopify
it's been a great platform for us
awesome uh what's the most popular
product that anyone buys
our most our best seller is the all-day
everyday pan um
which was our first product we started
with
and when you decide to launch new
products uh what do you have to see
or like how do you get the confidence to
launch something new knowing that that
very first product is still the most
popular one
yeah um i think a lot about like what
complements what do we already have
today and like you know if we've got a
certain product do we have
a top that you can wear with it or a
bottom that you can wear with it
then like on a higher level i think
about you know where are we as a brand
today and when we launched the brand it
was you know
really focused on the leisure space kind
of trying to stay away from the active
athletic space thinking that space is
more saturated and then like on the
other end of like
you know business casual work uh and so
we kind of gravitated more towards
business casual and work
um and so you know it's in buckets of
you know where does it fit within our
product offering and then
you know also what are we hearing from
customers and what do we think makes
sense a compliment what we
already have out there yeah what's your
biggest regret
over the last couple of years if you go
back and change one thing is there
anything that sticks out
i think i mean i know we've talked about
you know the hiring a good amount
and you know me being the only employee
i do wish that i had
hired a bit sooner both for customer
support and then
um you know our head of operations who
was our first hire
it just became apparent that like you
know getting good people on board
and you know helping the business scale
in that way
uh really opens up a lot uh in terms of
you know what i can focus on what more
we can be doing as a company
and so yeah i think that that's maybe
my biggest regret is kind of wishing i'd
hired sooner
yeah and when you think about uh that
regret that makes me ask the opposite
question which is what is your favorite
memory from last couple years
uh the one the memory that sticks out
the most that
is kind of funny now is we move
fulfillment centers um
this was a few years ago i'm still the
only employee
and at the time like i was i had a good
relationship with the existing
fulfillment center i was nervous to tell
them that i wanted to leave
ended up telling them and i didn't even
consider it but i
i'd show up with a u-haul truck and i
you know load the truck they kind of
help me load it
and then i drive it from new york to
chicago with my brother
um to a new fulfillment center and it
was like i didn't consider that i could
have hired someone
to you know help me load it to drive i
had never i
hadn't driven a truck like that before
and show up to the new fulfillment
center get up and it was like
all over the weekend so that we wouldn't
have that much missed time to fulfill
orders
um yeah it's just it's it's funny to
think about
but those to me like that story
specifically is almost like the fun of
it right like if you just hired people
to do all that other stuff like it's
almost like you wouldn't have that story
or that memory and so
uh sure you'd have a successful business
but to some degree like that seems to be
the uh the fun part of actually building
the company
definitely definitely what did you like
brother what did your brother think when
you were like hey man you're gonna come
come with me and we're going this drive
luckily he's an entrepreneur himself and
he was you know
happy to do it and yeah i mean it was it
was fun once we had like the stuff
loaded we were on the road it was
it was fun driving together yeah i uh
one of my brothers is uh is thinking
about moving
and we were just talking about this this
idea of like hey let's put it all in a
u-haul and then we'll drive and it'd be
you know pretty long 18-hour drive
and uh he literally told his girlfriend
he said oh we'll just like play music
and like hang out and have a blast and
so
i don't think that she thought it was
nearly gonna be as fun as we thought it
was
that's funny absolutely before uh before
i let you guys ask everyone the same
three questions you'll get to ask me uh
one to finish up what uh what's the most
important book you've ever read
i don't know if it's the most important
but the one i've enjoyed a lot recently
is shoe dog
um you know it's relevant but um
it's it's a book that like i've read
multiple times and then i'll read
you know parts of it just to like enjoy
like reread some of the stuff that i
love the most
um yeah it's just for me
yeah i really enjoy reading it how much
of it
is uh that story resonates with you
because it is
uh you know kind of an apparel-like
story or a company
um and some of the aspects of like the
supply chain and the difficulties and
complexities
you resonate with with compared to just
like the entrepreneurship story in
general
uh a lot there's a lot of similarities
and it's like you know we're not nikita
like the dream is one day
20 years whatever like 40 years um
but yeah there's a lot that's maybe one
of the reasons why i like it so much it
just feels like
there's a lot of similarities between
some of the problems he went through and
what it feels like i'm going through
wasn't even called nike at the time
right right that's right
uh second question is about your sleep
schedule
uh i'm gonna break this up i want uh
what was your sleep schedule this comes
from our friends over at eight sleep so
they've got this thermoregulation bed
uh i turn it super cold my wife turns it
really hot and
i still make a baby now but i used to
only sleep you know five six hours
uh what was your sleep schedule when you
didn't have any employees and then what
has it transitioned into
uh today uh it's pretty similar
i i've kind of always tried to get
seven to eight hours of sleep it's been
something that like has just been
important to me
uh i know that like if you know if i go
too many days without getting that i
won't be able to function and so
um yeah i i'm usually
yeah trying to get seven or eight hours
all right
you you were way ahead of the curve on
that one
last question you get to ask me one is
uh aliens
believer or non-believer
i'm a believer why
just like you know seeing some of the
seeing some of the dead out there the
research it just feels like
and and you know thinking about how big
everything is
um it feels more likely than not that
there are another
species out there yeah it feels like uh
probabilistically
yes right uh what shape they are in
right are they intelligent or not uh is
a whole different ball game but uh
it just feels like uh i even go as far
as they like i bet you mars has some
sort of
life it just may not be what we're all
thinking about you know the little green
man walking around
right right right could could be uh you
know literally
cells or something so who knows i'm not
a scientist but uh but i agree with you
i think
it's got to be life somewhere else yeah
yeah what uh what one question you have
for me to uh to wrap us up
i've got so uh my question is
what keeps you up at night what do you
think about or yeah
curious what you know yeah this is gonna
sound insane
but this is like a new worry uh i try to
balance
uh happiness with ambition and uh
my nature is to go 110
hard charging uh i wouldn't sleep if i
thought that that was a smart thing to
do anymore right like just like
just go for it all the time bigger
faster better
um but what i've noticed is like there's
a direct trade-off between like that
type of mentality and
um kind of pursuit with just
peace of mind and like happiness and so
like where the balance is
uh i'm not sure because if you just
optimize completely for happiness in
some way you almost feel lazy like
you feel like you're like not doing
anything which is almost a test of
happiness like can you do nothing and be
happy
right um but but i think that uh that
balance
is uh almost one of these things where
like you'll never actually get the right
answer
uh but the constant pursuit of the
balance between ambition and happiness
seems to be uh
at least right now you know kind of top
of mind and uh
it's funny to kind of hear you thinking
through and talking about you know when
you started to
hire people versus not hire people
whatever some of it is
can you you know be ambitious uh and
also maybe you don't have to do 100 of
the work right like is
does that kind of bring more happiness
or if you've got to manage people maybe
that actually makes you unhappy
right kind of depends on on the
situation
uh the individuals and kind of what
you're trying to accomplish but i think
that
that balance is probably the thing that
i spend the most time thinking about
right now
super interesting yeah that resonates
with me for sure
why i i think you know
similarly it's like can i be happy in
the moment like you know
i feel like the brand is is doing well
and we've accomplished a lot
and you know it's gotten to a place
where
you know a year two or three years ago
it would have been a dream to get to
this
place and you know see the numbers and
have the employees and
and it's hard to appreciate it and not
want more of like
okay we got to here let's get to the
next stage let's get to the next stage
and it's like
i don't know i think a lot about like
you know how you know
when do i feel like i've made it or you
know or a success or
and what does that feel like and yeah
absolutely uh where can we send people
to
uh pick up some clothes well hold on
first of all before you tell us
i have to say i've got a bunch of the
pants uh
shirt jacket i said the [ __ ] is actually
really comfortable like
i know you're saying it and like you're
you literally are
the founder of the company so you're
supposed to say it regardless but like
as somebody who
uh i don't buy designer clothes like i'm
like a five dollar
jeans from walmart type guy uh literally
just wear you know black t-shirts etc uh
it's super comfortable and so anyone
who's listening to this who's like i
don't know like
completely unfiltered advice uh or
feedback like it's really really
comfortable so where can people go uh
purchase anything especially the pants
if that's what they want
nice that's awesome to hear um very cool
uh our website is
uh publicrec.com uh
rec is rec like recreation so yeah
public
rec rec.com all right before i let you
go
you got to tell me where'd the name come
from uh
wearing clothes in public during
recreation which was like the thought of
it and it was just like
at the time it was a lot of back and
forth with one of my friends who was i
was like
like this and he would throw in so
i like the word public uh and i think
initially i tried to get public service
and i couldn't get that clear
through ip and so i landed on public
wreck
i love it man you're building an
absolute beast of a company so keep
going
i'm a big fan uh i wear the clothes and
anyone who wants go to
publicwrec.com and let's do it again in
the future awesome awesome it's good
talking to you